what do you think about the apology that
man is like a WWE star to me the Cadence
of the speech it was obviously heavily
prepared and maybe even entirely
scripted he doesn't seem sorry he
doesn't seem sad there is no part of
vulnerability in that it seems
unbelievably performative to me I didn't
feel sympathy for him all of the caveats
when it came to this is to do with
self-esteem the immediate misdirection
toward four thousand men a day killed
himself 80 000 for men a day tried to
take their own lives and stuff like that
it's like bro no one criticized you
about that no one even brought that up
he also said it's complicated you think
it's complicated you were called out for
taking and lying about